- Vorsicht, Nico. Du darfst nicht
so stark auftreten.
- Schon gut. Ich kann alleine laufen …
- Der Arzt schaut sich den
Fuß jetzt erst mal an.
- Hoffentlich müssen wir nicht lange warten.
- Das glaube ich nicht.
Wir haben ja einen Termin.
- Hallo!
- Hallo, guten Tag! Haben Sie einen Termin?
- Ja, ich hab' angerufen.
Unser Freund, Nico González,
hat Schmerzen am Fuß.
- Der Fuß sieht nicht gut aus.
- Haben Sie starke Schmerzen?
- Es tut weh.
- Der Arzt schaut sich das gleich an.
Er muss den Fuß sicher auch röntgen.
Vielleicht ist er gebrochen.
- Gebrochen?
- Was heißt gebrochen?
- Äh … Egal.
- Keine Sorge. Das steht ja
auch noch gar nicht fest.
Sie waren noch nie
hier in der Praxis, oder?
Dann hätte ich gerne
Ihre Versichertenkarte.
Sie haben doch eine Krankenversicherung?
- Ähm … Nico?
- Hier.
- Ja.
- Danke!
Bitte gehen Sie schon
mal in den Behandlungsraum.
Der Arzt ist gleich bei Ihnen.
- Okay. Danke!
- Bitte. Einmal hier lang.
Die brauch' ich noch. Die bring' ich Ihnen.
- Komm!